c'est le début du moyen-âge
les uns en fuite pousse le peuple
d'esclaves à envahir la grande plaine de
l'est de l'europe
tandis qu'en scandinavie les germains
suédois unifie la région du gotha landes
comme royaume de suède suivi par les
germains danois qui unissent leurs plans
formant le royaume du danemark
dans l' empire byzantin qui a chassé les
ostrogoths de l'italie règne la culture
grecque
l'empereur justinien établi son code qui
est encore la base législative actuelle
dont les lois et les droits sont les
mêmes pour tous
mais après avoir dû céder le nord de
l'italie aux germains lombard les
byzantins doivent affronter un plus
grand danger
arrivant d'arabie les armes et d'une
nouvelle fois l'islam après avoir
conquis les possessions orientale de
l'empiré byzantin avance vers les
balkans
ce sont les musulmans arrêtés par un peu
plus provenant des steps les bulgares
qui se dirige vers le bas danube
les musulmans passent alors par
l'afrique envahissent la péninsule
ibérique et écrase les wisigoths
les musulmans seraient même rentré en
france si le duc francs charles martel
ne les avaient arrêtés à poitiers
l'airbus ans dans les stands les francs
sont à leur puissant et le royaume
s'étend avec charlemagne charlemagne roi
guerrier repousse les musulmans du nord
de l'espagne et fonds de l'état de
l'andorre pour se protéger des invasions
arabes
puis ils annexent les pays germain
paupières l'italie du nord et se posant
en défenseurs de l'église
il donne à la papauté dépossession en
italie permettant la création des états
pontificaux en récompense il est sacré
empereur romain d'occident
avec toutes les manifs is ans et les
titres de l'ancienne rome
charlemagne est le souverain le plus
puissant de l'europe médiévale mais son
énorme empire morcelée en une multitude
de principauté avec des coutumes et des
langues différentes est difficile à
unifier au traité de verdun
il est partagé entre les trois petits
fils de charlemagne
naissent alors l'ancienne france à
l'occident de lempire la lotharingie en
son centre et l'ancien germany à son
orient tout de confession chrétienne
cet équilibre va vite se doubler car une
nouvelle invasion arrive du nord des
peuples germains de scandinavie les
vikings suédois établissent des
comptoirs pour leur commerce avec
l'entretien russe où ils fondent l'état
de kiev qu'ils appellent ruthénie tandis
que d'autres vikings les norvégien et
danois
après avoir dévasté l'angleterre
débarque en france et la ravage jusqu'à
obtenir un duché qui prend le nom de
normandie
à l'est de l'europe
la bulgarie arrive à sa plus grande
extension territoriale
les slaves polan constitue le puissant
royaume de pologne et les slaves tchèque
forme lempire de la grande moravie tous
convertis au christianisme
cependant la grande moravie et conquise
par un peuple provenant des steppes les
hongrois ils parviennent même à dévaster
la germanique arrêté paris-berlin des
hongrois s'installe alors dans la plaine
des carpates se convertissent au
catholicisme et fonde le royaume de
hongrie
à cette époque la germanie est un état
très puissant et son roi au ton premier
a des ambitions impériales il fonde le
marquisat d'autriche pour former une
barrière aux incursions des hongrois
puis il envahit la lotharingie enitan y
entrent en triomphant dans rome où le
pape le couronne empereur du saint
empire romain germanique
c'est le premier h
dans les ardennes le compte six jeux
froid achète un vieux château fort
romain et le renforce pour y fonder le
comté du luxembourg vassal de l' empire
germanique en scandinavie le peuple
vikings des norvégiens forme le royaume
de norvège dans les balkans les
byzantins annexe la bulgarie mais ils
perdent le sud de l'italie
la sicile et l'île de malte où ce
occupée par les normands
les normands de guillaume le conquérant
envahissent même l'angleterre
mais ils sont repoussés d'irlande
dans la péninsule italique les premiers
états italiens se forme dont les
républiques marine de gênes et de pise
chasse les musulmans de la méditerranée
les musulmans sont battus aussi en
espagne où le roi catholique de castille
commence la reconquista de la péninsule
reconnaissant l'indépendance au portugal
la france par contre affronte un grand
danger car l'un de ses vassaux le comte
d'anjou henry deux possesseurs de la
normandie de la bretagne et de
l'aquitaine hérite aussi du trône
d'angleterre est désormais à la tête de
l' empire plantagenêt il défie la france
entre temps le saint empire germanique
continue son expansion sur les rives de
la baltique incorporant les actuels
lettonie et l'estonie habité par des
peuples païens
le royaume de hongrie sept ans
tandis que l' empire byzantin repousse
les roumains du royaume valaques mais
perd la bulgarie devenu un royaume
indépendant
à cette époque
est occupée par l'occupation musulmane
de jérusalem le pape grégoire huit
appellent les nobles chrétiens à la
libération de la terre sainte et
organise les croisades leroy 3 et
angleterre richard coeur de lion prend
aussitôt chi aux musulmans
mais quand les anglais attaquent la
france le roi philippe auguste les bas
et confisqué leurs possessions
françaises
dans les pays baltes le grand duché
payen de lituanie est fondée l'estonie
et la lettonie sont occupées par le
danemark et les chevaliers 2 tonique un
ordre de nobles germain croisée de
retour de jérusalem prennent des
possessions en plus
la suède se christiane is et annexes la
finlande habitée par des tribus sans
cohésion politique
la ruthénie est envahie par les mongols
tard
en italie les républiques marine de
venise jeunes hippies accroissent leur
puissance en conflit avec l' empire
germanique
elle enlève les îles grecques aux
byzantins et chip aux anglais
à rome
les conflits avec les swaps de six ils
provoquent l'appel au secours du pape
clément iv au roi de france louis 9
connu sous le nom de saint louis qui
envoie alors une armée commandée par son
frère charles d'anjou
mais en sicile les français sont
repoussés par les espagnols d'aragon qui
débarque en occupant le sud de l'italie
au centre de l'italie le pape permet
l'indépendance de la cité république de
saint marin et au nord de l'italie
la principauté de monaco déclare son
indépendance vis-à-vis de la république
de gênes
en 1300 les alliances se produite par
les mariages entre les souverains
d'europe conduisent leurs héritiers à de
violentes controverses en angleterre le
roi edouard iii revendique la couronne
de france en tant que petit fils du roi
français ce qui provoque la guerre de
cent ans
au danemark la reine catholique
marguerite deux premières unifie la
norvège et la suède sous sa couronne le
saint-empire romain germanique hérité
par la maison autrichienne d'apps bourg
devient lempire d'autriche mais c'est
300 et n'obéissent que de loin à
l'empereur l'un de ces états la suisse
se dote alors d'une puissante armée
proclame son indépendance et s'institue
en confédération de canton
à l'est de l'europe les tatars abandonne
la ruthénie
en lituanie le grand-duc que joe gatti
là se marie avec la princesse de pologne
et fonde l'union de pologne lituanie
puis il envahit la ruthénie et écrase
les chevaliers teutoniques prend dans la
prusse vassal de son nouveau royaume